zach you've been generous to send us
your
script for take back my pleasure
so we'd love to do a page one analysis
sure so for page one of take back
can you talk about the world you were
trying to create yeah absolutely
um this was basically again we go back
to
that opening image and really wanting to
get a grip a
grasp of what this film is about right
off the bat
essentially hitting the audience at the
head so they know what kind of film this
is going to be
and we're in a dark you know we're in a
van we're not sure where
we're not sure with who uh but we can
get
you know we can guess pretty quickly
that it's a young woman um
and she's in a bag and she's tied up and
we're not sure what that is happening
doors are thrown open
and she's held out by a bunch of seedy
looking guys
and we hear voices and
we can pretty much grasp that she's been
taken she's been kidnapped
and she's going to be used
to make these guys money somehow and we
can only guess our worst
our worst nightmare or her worst
nightmare is really what happens
and that sort of sets up the story and
that was essentially going back to what
is that opening image and how's that
going to set up the story
what does it mean for genre does it mean
for character what is it that we see
right away and how are we going to get
everyone invested right off the bat how
many characters are introduced in this
page one scene
well again and i don't want to give i
don't want to give too much away um
i won't give too much away um we do meet
uh mickey rourke's character uh this
will be him
who comes through and we do meet the
well i'll just leave it at that
i will say who we it's three it's three
characters
who we meet right from the get-go from
that opening page
so you introduce one of the characters
as a vacant-looking man
rather than the character name right and
that actually i can say that that winds
up being
um mickey rourke's uh the carrot
mickey works character whose name is
patrick um
winds up being his um doomed brother
i personally like to
reveal as little up front as possible
um making it
um you know keeping as much mystery
involved
and keeping that reader turning the page
um which are obviously tied together is
so in my
in my um
uh process is so imperative
um giving out just little bits and
pieces
here and there again i know for some
writers it seems like it's
you know par for the course that's the
way it should be but
you know it's not always the easiest
thing because you don't want to reveal
too much information
you want it to you know just slowly come
in in drips
and drips and keep it going
and um it's you know it's not always
easy to do
it's not always easy to do but um in
this instance yes i wanted to just
leave when i say vacant looking man you
know
he'll be coming back later as a vacant
looking man but
then eventually we understand who he is
and where he's identified
in the in the story so as you said
earlier
moving the story forward but again with
drips you don't you just want to hint at
things
absolutely keeping the pacing going i
never
and again this is just me i i am very
fastidious about this
it's like you know scenes should be
about two pages
when you're writing each scene should be
two pages so if you're writing they
always say
60 60 scenes if you will times 2 120
pages
obviously the length of films have come
down so
i always try to think about maybe 40
scenes
um and conflict within those 40
you know those 40 scenes i should say
earlier um
within the blake snyder thing there are
the 15 beats
that he then expands to 40 beats within
a story
so for me it's and i think you could be
anywhere between 30 and 40.
um but you figure those 40 beats are
usually between
you know two and three pages roughly is
what you're aiming for
um so so yeah it and
again i apologize for not expanding upon
that earlier but
just initially getting a sense of the
main beats for the character
then expanding those and that takes you
through the rest of the story for the
most part
for me keeping scenes between
two to three pages and keeping action
lines
never clumping them really keeping it
sparse
letting the story flow letting the
script and you know screenwriting is
very different than prose writing
screen lining is very it's punchier you
don't want to write a lot of superfluous
description you want to keep it short
you want to keep it compact you want to
get to the point right away
and that also has that also ties into
the pacing
of of your story um
at least it does for me and i and that
that is that's part of the flow
so again keeping keeping it um
you know keeping it tight keeping it
punchy
lots of white page and just letting it
letting it flow
letting it flow a fluid fluid script you
don't want to get too clumped up
and you want to keep the pages turning
so action line van rolls to a stop
next line side door is thrown open right
blinding light floods in yeah
right just and there there is like a
rhythm
there's always a rhythm shadow shrouded
faces appear rough uncompromising hands
grab pull and drag us out i can
i can see it i can feel like i'm there
right yeah
and you want and and again this is this
is not
it it's you may get you may have to go
through
seven eight nine drafts before you get
that rhythm down that's why
rewriting is so important first draft
you get it down great good for you
there's going to be a lot more there's
going to be subsequent drafts where
you're really trying to find that pacing
finding that rhythm finding that that
flow to it
that's all part of the process and it's
certainly for me and that's what that's
what took me
again i've i wrote many drafts for the
script until i really got
to that point where i'm like okay
it flowed it flowed how many drafts
over the years easily 25 30
it was a lot in all various stages not
complete page one rewrites but
definitely different versions writing
different rewriting different scenes
can you tell us about the smash cut i
it's funny because i don't usually don't
like
putting in i try to avoid stage
directions as much as possible
or cuts you know cut twos uh
i'm very limited with those if i'm doing
it it has
it's it's there for to have a profound
effect on
you know your match it's almost like a
match cut from
um you know your character in one
scene's punching
and the next scene that character is
punching
or another character's punching so it's
sort of like that smash cut
it's it's a quick cut to sort of match
to to gel the two scenes together in a
very fast way
normally i don't like putting in um
again stage directions or you know those
inserts
can you tell us about the smash cut
though literally it seems like was it a
happy accident or deliberate it was on
the bottom
yeah that that very well may have i
think it was
um that was the end of the scene and i
it was probably more of a happy accent
than anything else
but it was great because it ended on
that first page so
hopefully they're reading to the second
page when they see that
how long did it take you to write this
first page well it was again it was it
was rewritten
um but something like that again i mean
i
it was i i don't have a ti i don't have
a time frame for that
but you know there are times where i've
been able to write a page like that
within a couple of minutes
other times it takes longer because
again i'm refining it and i'm finding my
way
but it it can vary a whole a whole lot
of different
you know a length of time for
that particular process and when you
said you did
roughly 25 rewrites i realized they
weren't all page one rewrites but
what part in particular did you work
most at that needed the most positive oh
uh most mostly her journey
um changing it for you know
um because
funny enough mickey rourke's character
was a woman
really but we got mickey and i was like
they said can you make this a man i said
sure
why not and you know mickey rourke why
not sure
that definitely changed that dynamic a
little bit but
i think it had more to do with her
journey and her character and then at
other times
making the plot making it fresher
updating it
i would say at certain points some of
the action
you know i think for the most part um
you know it's zara now but in the script
it's sarah the zara character
or sarah sorry i did change her along
the way and
there was definitely certain changes but
she always was kind of like
again i i stuck you know it was this
woman who
committed this act of heroism she was
trying to escape her past
had the spotlight turned back on her and
you know all the all the bugs came out
under the light to
make her life a living hell and she had
to fight back
and take her life back so that was kind
of always that was pretty much always
there
um so but uh there were always tweaks
that i made to
again her story and her background and
just to make it more compelling
and her more compelling is this first
page still the opening of the movie
i don't know i don't i don't think it is
okay judging from the trailer too i'm
not sure
i don't think it is okay yeah well i
don't want to say anything sadly
okay jeopardize it because i really like
that opening
but again can't be wedded to our work
yeah you get paid and it's like
looking back at it now with the first
page take back
were there any mistakes anything you
feel like you could have done better or
are you happy
with exactly how it flows
i do like the flow i am
i'm never going to say i'm satisfied but
i'm happy with where it's at
at the moment somebody came around and
said hey we could do this i'd be like
great
i like that idea let's do it amenable to
it
i think filmmaking is so much about
collaboration and
hearing other people out kind of like
life which we've
kind of eschewed lately i feel that
you should always be willing to hear
what people have to say even if you
don't like the idea
hear them out don't dismiss it outright
if it's the most inane
effing idea you okay
but somebody may just as an aside say
yeah but you might think about um
you know giving her um you know a little
charm blaze that you can bring back
later or something like that
as a symbol bad example but think about
it that's a really good idea
work that in or some way symbolize that
symbol term
uh ties back to the theme
um so
where it's at now i i think it
accomplishes what it needs to
i think it sets up the sets up the film
with some mystery
we get a sense of danger we get a sense
of establishing what genre does
we get a nice opening image um
so yeah but um
and i will backtrack that getting to
that opening image
the actual writing of it didn't take
long but i think
working around some scenes that had been
there prior and making it
that took some reshifting and some
rewriting
the actual scene itself to write wasn't
too didn't take too long but
there was definitely parts of drafts
that were different that had different
opening images and i think
for me it was about streamlining it and
making it as concise and simple and
quick as possible
again that's how i work i want to know
you know
delving into it as quickly as possible
and getting
to the story you know and getting to our
our characters and and and getting to
those
those main beats as fast and concisely
as possible is so important
did you cut down a lot of dialogue and
of the action
lines um it's not too much
there were some there were some um
yeah probably uh maybe you know in that
instance maybe a quarter a half a page
yeah because they didn't really need to
be much that needed to be said
that's what i that wasn't my intention
again i think you do more
by showing more and saying less take
back
coming out in 2020 2021 i'm i'm
i don't quote me it should be coming out
in
between april and june we're hoping
it's some i'd just say the spring at
some point in the spring
maybe mid to late spring right and it
was shot during covid
it was shot during kovid it was one of
the few movies made during covet it was
shot in la
and out in the palm springs area yes
right and it stars
stars mickey rourke michael jai white
gillian white james russo and a handful
of other
actors and actresses who you've
definitely seen
at a theater near you or on television
so yeah
yeah it was a really good cast really um
they did a terrific job with the casting
without a doubt and i know it
took a little bit to get made and were
yeah it was it was it was definitely a
process
um we had uh you know again um
uh i had uh met uh
through um i had sent the script to a
producer friend of mine
and he had gotten it to
christian sesma who's the director and
my captain who's a producer
both have worked extensively in the
business mike is actually as an actor he
was in
the green book and a number of other
films
christians worked on a number he
christian actually has
just had a film come out early this year
with val kilmer called
pater and he's
directed a number of other films um
and yeah so we went to them and
you know they they signed on pretty
quickly
and then we were able to get mickey work
attached and
we unfortunately had an investor drop
out
and we needed to fill that so we went to
a financier fairly big finance here in
town
who stepped in and
we unfortunately weren't able to get it
done with him
so we we signed on and then it just it
just didn't happen
and then we the rights reverted back to
me and
after that we were able to find a
finance here pretty quickly
plug the the budget shortfall that we
had had from
uh the initial investor backing out
and um we got it made and
it's it'll be out soon excellent okay
and we'll have a trailer
of course in the link below yeah
absolutely that is the official trailer
you